[Music]
wow damn you look good you're so
cute doesn't it look like me now
always look at this little teddy bear
are you ready to get for forun are you
going to get a good fortune can babies
get Fortune it's sh happy New Year we're
going to get our Fortune to see what
kind of luck we will get in the next
year uh last year we got tiny Fortune
which makes sense right here you're
[Music]
tiny all right your boy got the best one
great good luck ven got good
luck and Mar I got small luck small so
small small peasant Lu great start of
the Year wouldn't you
[Music]
[Applause]
say over
[Music]
here
mom is naturally
hilarious so you're supposed to burn
these at the New Year's on the temple at
at night since we're new parents we
didn't have the time so we're going to
burn you at home I don't know if this
is it's probably not you're supposed to
do how do I smash it with a
hammer oh man he's getting destroyed
thany it's time to burn you up mother
okayy I hope it burns
[Music]
well
this little chubster needs more clothes
cuz you're too big look at these
[Music]
hands we in
Kawasaki to go for to an aquarium for be
we went when he was really young
but uh we kind of wanted to see his
reaction to all the fishes and stuff I
don't know we'll see how he likes
it fish yes it is it is a fish say hi to
fishy he looks just like you
wow
[Music]
who slow down
partner oh my God I never seen one
either wow
[Music]
be what did you say bye
bya
[Music]
awesome too
bad
we got a spinky there the guy on Tik Tok
that does it I'm trying to hit Mar's
head I can't do it from this angle I
wait if I open the card I can
[Applause]
do I can't do I need more practice I
need to watch more Tik
Tok doblin rainbow
woohoo
[Music]
woohoo you're going to meet your
grandparents
[Music]
be so excited faruru far is coming yay
yay
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
[Music]
we're getting a
massage parents get tempered I never
gotten a massage I don't know if it
would be nice but we were gifted so
we'll see how it
[Music]
goes I'm eating this squid
pasta
[Music]
I love this smow thank you come
in
[Music]
yeah
e
that's the sweet in
[Music]
him
byebye
bye all right wiky
feet look at this normal beautiful
foot what is
that mindset pushed me down the
stair your slippers are in the way so
technically I think
I think that
means I'm coming to bite
you we going to have Buffet are you
ready for
[Music]
Buffet got a brand new
Slinky oo
okay D is so cute well the outfit is
cute it's cter than my very accurate
right there oh
avocado
avocado what do I do that b you stick
everything in your mouth come on
back ohly
[Music]
M oh so
delicious
[Music]
Jo
you ready do you trust
me yeah yeah okay keep your head
straight a lot of
hair it looks good on camera so that's
good I think it's pretty good healthy
hair maxia has brought home the worst
thing in the entire Tire I I never seen
something so disgusting I had to make
her move it it's up
there it's a mushroom farm oh God I
don't want to touch it I can't be the
only one who thinks this is so
disgusting oh my God can you put it
back I pulled it out I don't want to
T oh
God I'm never eating
mushrooms
[Music]
ah
now it looks like I go to Starbucks I
don't go to Starbucks that was a
coincidence we are in Nishi something uh
there's a chopping Street here we want
to check out yeah it is pretty
long you want to go to game Goose
tonight where the gaming
[Music]
happens oh my God
why
that was not even close maybe this was
the
longest Never
[Music]
End why is it n and I'm back
on
what are you
doing is mommy being funny is mommy
being funny yes oh my God she's so
[Music]
funny
[Laughter]
he went
[Music]
off look at this
beauty it's fuka pizza oh my God
my m m
m that good well good you
dous I would be too God
damn J we're going to I'm man
Museum yes we are I hear the
[Music]
music so this is one of the biggest kids
cartoons in Japan we don't know the lore
cuz be doesn't watch cartoons yet all I
know it's a bread it's a bread
man this is such a crazy
view we're in Yokohama by the way it is
extremely busy here we went to the
restaurant and it was a 3 hour and 20
minute way so maybe not we can't enter
the museum
though absolute
[Music]
Madness too
intense J is too small to play anyway so
we bailed model Railway
Museum we just entered a random building
to get shelter and we're like oh this
could want to check
out so
pretty
[Music]
wow
all right that turned out to be
great super
pretty Sweden luck in the
[Music]
unluck yay
what a happy
[Music]
boy